[Music]
I'm Quincy Larson teacher and founder of
freeo Camp each week we're talking to
developers entrepreneurs and ambitious
people who are getting into Tech and
today we are thrilled to welcome PA
borgan great to be here yeah and and uh
we are so excited to have you here of
course per is the founder of scrimba he
is a software engineer turned Tech
founder uh who's gone through like y
combinator runs a very popular website
uh that teaches coding we published many
of those courses on the free code Camp
YouTube channel and I'm just thrilled to
sit down and talk with you because we've
never had you on the on the podcast yet
after more than 100 episodes so it feels
like a bit of an
Omission yeah also just note that I'm
recovering from like a pretty serious
cough that had me like completely
debilitated for like a week so if I have
a coughing fit or anything uh just know
that I'm fine I'm just Echoes of my
previous Illness but um per where where
you are are are you over in Oslo right
now yes we are based uh here out of Oslo
where the founding team is from and and
where yeah we all live awesome well I'm
very interested as an American uh in you
know I'm I'm from Scandinavia originally
my family came over from Sweden which I
know is different from Norway but uh I'm
I'm always very interested in in that
kind of region you know the land of
Vikings and uh I know that Norway is a
very small country but it's a it's a
very influential country on the world
stage and it has a ton of natural beauty
so I have to ask what was it like
growing up in
Norway so uh I'm from the capital uh
Oslo uh from the city so to be honest I
don't I I I never really went to the the
most beautiful places uh until I was uh
an adult or not not not much at least
but uh of course it's it's a great place
to live uh good uh good good system uh
welfare system but but with freedom as
well and with uh skiing and nature and
yeah great place you should you should
come and visit us awesome it's
definitely on my bucket list of places
to visit uh so how would you compare
like the Norwegian Tech scene uh with
San Francisco in Silicon Valley where I
know you've spent quite a bit of time
over these past few
years yeah so it's um much smaller of
course and it's it's quite um it's less
ambitious I would say or at least when I
started out uh as a founder and like 10
years ago or so uh there was a lot fewer
startups and every time we I've gone to
San Francisco have been been coming back
super pumped and and twice as ambitious
uh which is a sometimes a good thing
other other uh at other times it's uh
you want to be a bit more frugal and
care about the fundamentals and and the
next step and not the big dream so um I
think we've kind of with scrim bot tried
to struck a balance between being
inspired a little bit by the the
American ambition and and also by by the
like uh down toe
uh way of running companies in Norway
but it is changing it it's becoming more
and more uh International startups out
of scan or out of Norway Sweden has had
many over the last decades but but
Norway's been lagging a little bit
behind but it it's it's getting better
yeah yeah well Norway of course is like
an economic Powerhouse like per capita
GDP I think is maybe the highest in the
world
uh and a lot of that is because you all
have all this abundant mineral wealth
did uh did you hear about like the
discovery of the massive phosphate
reserves and some of these other Rare
Earth minerals uh I think it was maybe
off the coast so so I have this thing
right now where I actually don't read
the news it's kind of my my New Year's
commitment where I try to stay away from
the news because it just kills my
productivity so I've heard a little bit
about it but to be honest you probably
know more about it than I do okay cool
well that that's interesting so you
completely cut the news out of your
day-to-day is that like a New Year's
resolution yes that what I meant yeah
resolution that's the word it is uh so
because I just find that it's such a
struggle to to stay productive with all
the The Temptations out there H and and
news and social media being the like the
most important ones got to got to kind
of make some rules for myself in order
to stay away from it yeah I can
definitely relate to that uh like I have
kind of like tuned out a lot of the
election related news here in the United
States cuz I already know how I'm voting
so it's not going to change anything so
uh why spend a whole lot of time like
going over the the Gory details of the
you know Democratic process um I I
realize that that may sound like a very
privileged take but um I've got a lot of
stuff to do and I can't be following the
every uh the every unfolding of all
these different uh you know drama that
are that are going on I can just read
about it in Wikipedia few years from now
and figure out what the conclusion was
without having to go along for the
entire ride so yeah or like watch the
evening news or something if a couple of
times a week that's more that's what
people did back in the good old days or
good old it did like 20 years ago and
that worked totally F pre social media
days yes yeah so I'm very interested in
delving into your background because you
have a pretty unique background uh among
Tech Founders and developers so you
actually studied economics in college
but then you went and you worked as a
software developer for like five years
maybe you can talk about how you got
into coding and how you were able to get
those those first few jobs as a
developer maybe you can just kind of
give us like an origin story if you will
yeah so so I didn't work as a software
developer for five years actually it was
short than that it was like uh between
one and two years after I I graduated
from the boot camp and then um I've been
coding at scrimba for like the last
seven years here and there of course but
but now now you go to a boot camp then
yeah or it was a free peerto Paar driven
boot camp in London so it was like no
teachers and just a bunch of people
thrown together uh who who um got a task
every week like this week you're going
to build a blog or an e-commerce site or
whatever and it was our responsibility
to learn from each other and help each
other and kind of uh together build that
that Weekly product it's called s like
cool kind of what was it Founders and
coders yeah I've heard Founders and
coders yeah yeah and and that always
like struck me because it's it's free
and it's it's kind of peer-to-peer based
it's very different from the
conventional coding boot camp models
that we had like in San Francisco for
example um exactly so you hung out there
with a bunch of other ambitious people
who were trying to learn coding and
essentially you kind of like selftaught
in tandem yeah um I did that and that
was kind of coming off the back of uh
running a startup that failed uh with
with the same co-founder that I started
scrimba with a bit later but we we we
tried to build like kids apps uh on
iPhone and iPad and and books and old
fairy tales and stuff like that we we
did kids entertainment essentially um
that failed um and I felt really almost
at the time almost a bit stupid for not
knowing how to code I felt like what am
I doing in this tech industry and
working with products if I really don't
know how to like build uh anything or
debug anything or fix anything so I just
had a a strong urge to to learn to code
H and that's so then I went uh to
Founders and coders was fantastic and
got a job at a startup when I came back
to Oslo
uh and worked there for uh a little over
a year and then cindra and I kind of uh
got the band back together and and and
did another um startup attempt which
just went uh went better yeah absolutely
well that that's a really cool so it
kind of like your your um I guess
imposter syndrome as a Founder who
couldn't code compelled you to like show
that up so that you can code and of
course now you code all the time and
you've built out this skill set this
developer mindset and actual kind of
Hands-On understanding of implementation
details of apps to the point that you
even taught courses and things like that
so uh yeah that's really cool maybe you
can talk about your co-founder a little
bit like how did you how did you two
meet yeah so we met at um coworking
space in Oslo when the the startup scene
in Oslo was very small so it was a kind
of the almost the only co-working space
for Founders in OSA at the time and he
was um he was working on his own project
I was working with the kids books and we
kind of realized that his skill set and
um our and the business uh we me and we
had a third Co co-founder that we had
built at the time was very like
complimentary so we kind of got together
and and started that company and what's
interesting is that he's he's a
brilliant engineer like the best
engineer I've worked with and he
actually after uh the first company
failed he went off and um worked on his
own self-made programming language and
started Consulting with his own
self-made programming language which is
like a terrible idea for the people he
consults for because he was the only
person who knew how to to write code in
that
language so he he then needed to um
create documentation for that uh and
started realizing that writing
documentation is really boring so he
started recording videos to teach people
about this language which is called
imba uh but just realizing or just
trying to record videos he realized what
a bad process it is for both the
teachers and the students to record uh
coding tutorials because as a teacher
you have to like be really careful about
setting up your system correctly about
editing the video about making sure
everything is polished about not talking
yourself into a corner and there's tons
of like
uh adjacent skills that you need in
addition to being like good at
explaining
things and uh once you've done all of
that and spent like an hour creating
like 10 minutes of of of a polish
tutorial it ends up as a video which
isn't interactive for the student either
so it's it's kind of taken all the data
and reduced it to dead pixels all the
metadata so it's a bad experience for
the student and for the teacher and
that's what what made him like hm maybe
we can make a coding tutorial in like
video based coding tutorials in a better
way and kind of rethink it from first
principles and he did that and kind of
invented the prototype for for scrimba
which eventually then became yeah the
company we are today yeah yeah and I I
remember very early days like that I was
just floored by this technology because
it I mean at a fundamental level it
wasn't anything
technologically uh you know fancy it was
just like what you said revisiting video
from first principles and saying like
hey why don't we you know sync up like
this HTML with this audio essentially
exactly and and for anybody out there
who hasn't used scrimba you should go to
scrimba and use it and just get a feel
for how you press play sound starts
playing you know slides can pop up and
you can pause it at any point and and
the actual Dom is being manipulated so
that the code in the code edor editor is
editable and you can just click play and
it'll just keep going but you can pause
it at any moment it it
code is like unique in this perspective
that like you couldn't do this if you
were like having like uh maybe you could
do it with like a video game system like
where you like sync the video up uh like
like speed demo archive like the old
Quake demos they were literally
coordinate data for where the person was
like bunny hopping over and shoot rocket
jumping and stuff and you could kind of
pause it and you could you could like
look around and stuff that's basically
like what you did for coding in the
sense that coding is just text and it's
it's not that heavy and you can just
render it in the Dom where it lives
JavaScript is like the language of the
web right so it's just like a web native
I almost consider scrimba more of a dis
a discovery than an invention in the
sense that nobody thought to do it that
way yeah but that's like cindra uh my
co-founder he's he's the kind of guy who
who really when he sees something broken
he just like gets an urge to fix it and
and then turn or rebuild it uh based on
first principles and I think something
you said there which is like the uh the
weight of it h is key because a scrim is
essentially just some tiny very very uh
optimized pieces of data uh that uh kind
of describe the changes that are
happening in the Dom and makes it feel
and look like a video H so so so kind of
the bandwidth you need to watch a scrim
compared to a video is like two orders
of magnitude less which is part of the
reason we've seen great success like all
over the world in areas especially where
the the internet internet access is slow
yeah yeah because I I remember that was
one of the big selling points of
scrimber early on is like it's like 1%
of a YouTube video in terms of bandwidth
consumption and a lot of that is because
video you're you're being very uh I
guess uh imperative in the sense that
you're telling every pixel what it's
supposed to look like and yes there's
like a compression algorithm and stuff
like that but for the most part you're
literally tracking like billions of
pieces of data for like a short video
right yeah um so it's inherently data
intensive whereas yeah audio is a tiny
fraction you know especially if you're
using like uh like I think we use 96
kilobytes for our podcast for example 96
kilobit per second or something like
that that's tiny that's like uh half a
megabyte per minute uh video I mean
once you add you and me on the screen
and stuff it's probably like closer to I
don't know 10
megabits per 10 megabytes per minute or
something like that at least uh it just
dramatically changes it so that was one
of the huge killer uh I guess
applications for scrimber early on was a
lot of folks don't live
in San Francisco where they have gigabit
internet and it's trivial for them to
like watch 4K video on YouTube or
whatever right A lot of people are you
know putting money onto a phone card on
like a data plan so they can you know be
able to text and and maybe read some
textual articles like Wikipedia or
something and make some phone calls and
stuff and scrimba is something that is
kind of within their budget like even if
you are on one of those kinds of plans
where where you're paying and and the
data prices in some parts of the world
are exorbitant but that's it is what
they it is what it is right like you
have to kind of adapt to that and so
scrimba has represented like this huge
windfall for people who don't have a lot
of data yeah and and just as a final
thing uh which we haven't actually
leaned into but also which is very uh
real is the the the computational power
and the and the um the electricity that
is used like the the carbon footprint
essentially of um serving a scrim and
sending it over the network
is also a lot less I mean I would assume
those two um graphs would scale like
like the size uh and and the carbon
footprint as well so but we haven't used
we should probably have used that in our
marketing a lot more but we haven't done
that but that so so many so many I
remember in the beginning cnra just
explained all these benefits and the
list goes on like with metadata
and yeah the bandwidth the carbon
footprint so much so was kind of even
though I was a little bit scared for
like jumping on a new startup at the
time I remember that was kind of what
convinced me when I realized that this
is just like a fundamentally better way
of doing it and if we don't build it
someone else I I thought at least would
eventually as you said discover this and
build them themselves but but it is
actually quite quite a lot of difficult
technicalities in it like making um a
prototype is perhaps not that hard but
making it uh polished and work well with
the cursor and responsiveness and all
that is and bundling and running the
projects has has shown to be quite a
challenge we spent a lot of time and
money U yeah making it work well yeah
well I'm you know I'm kind of surprised
that like a whole bunch of other
companies didn't see this and
immediately clone what you were doing uh
but I'm not that surprised in the sense
that like you think that like there's
going to be this really intense
competition when you have something that
people want but like a lot of big
companies and stuff they're just
distracted they got all these other
things going on and uh yeah like they're
going for like I guess more mass market
like the audience for people learning
the code is relatively small there are
only about 30 million professional
developers in the world I'd estimate
that there are another 30 million or so
people that are trying to actively learn
to code and um that's not like Facebook
or Instagram type total addressable
markets right so I think a lot of people
just it doesn't occur to them as like a
niche that's worth going after which is
good you know for you and me because we
we can serve those people without having
to deal with like a whole lot of
competition yeah I I think another thing
there is it's very hard for us to expand
our catalog because we have to add
support for every single thing we we uh
we want to create a course on as opposed
to a video based platform where you can
create courses on anything you can
because you just record a video of it so
so for that reason it's kind of been
hard for us actually to go more into the
to the B2B and the Enterprise Market
where they have very wide requirements
in terms of what kind of clippers and
stuff like that we are the niche is kind
of yeah protecting us a bit Yeah but to
be fair what you're offering is very
different from what they're offering
because you know to some extent like
video courses that have a teacher
explaining a concept and maybe have some
project that you Cod along home you
could argue that that's somewhat
commoditized in the sense that anybody
can sit down and create a really killer
tutorial and publish it on YouTube and
get an audience right so but to actually
build what you've built which is like
very thoughtfully deliberately designed
interactive pedagogy that is very
difficult you need people that have
thought a lot about that or who have
like you know a lot of teaching
experience and a lot of software
development experience who can kind of
figure out an optimal way to do that and
that's something like to talk about fre
go for a second that's something we're
very proud of is our core interactive
curriculum we we use YouTube as kind of
like u a place where we can have videos
on every topic but when it comes to the
core topics that we think every
developer should learn you know the git
and the Linux and the SQL and the Python
and the JavaScript HTML CSS like we can
really take time to build like a
deliberate curriculum that teaches those
skills in an interactive way and so see
in many ways what scrimba is doing is
like a different form of interactive
than what free C Camp is doing but it's
incredibly
valuable yeah and I mean free cold cam
has been an inspiration for us uh ever
since we started giving out courses so
yeah the admiration goes uh both ways
for
sure yeah and I I should point out that
that uh you have personally taught some
of the courses on the Freo Camp YouTube
channel and uh and some of your you know
I think Bob zerol yeah is that his name
yeah yes amazing teacher like so many so
many great teachers coming out of the
scrimba camp that are um hanging out and
helping kind of essentially take the
existing learning resources and Port
them to kind of like almost backward
compatibility you're back porting them
to the old video format but it's still
cool to have them in video because that
reaches a whole lot of people that are
on YouTube and then hopefully many of
those people go and do the interactive
versions of those courses on scrimba
yeah yeah so I have so much I want to
talk to you about I want to be mindful
of your time but uh maybe you could just
very quickly uh tell us like what are
some of the the main advantages of
learning on scrimba as opposed to
watching like the video version of a
scrimba
video yeah so um the key point is that H
you are forced to get your hands on the
code uh yeah hands on the keyboard sorry
um and write code we kind of have this
internal rule where if the student
hasn't coded the concept or the learning
objective in mind for the scrim then we
don't consider it to have been taught we
haven't like forced them to like now you
take over and do this Challenge and then
I will come and show you the solution
afterwards like don't skip over it
because the only one you're fooling by
doing that is yourself so it's kind of
that which is the core benefit uh most
people um um talk about when they when
they try scrimba and and report back
that they love but also as you said we
put a lot of cont like a lot of effort
into our courses into making them uh not
like most other courses out there at
least most other courses when we started
out uh because we we never teach things
just for the sake of of teaching the
theory it's always an underlying purpose
for why we're teaching something it's
like it's like it's it's almost not like
you're coming to us to learn JavaScript
it's like you're coming to us and yes
the course is called learn JavaScript
but once you're into the course it's
like hey how about how cool would it be
to have this little blackjack game or
this little app that actually solves a a
use case in your business for tracking
sales leads in your Chrome extension
like imagine building something like and
having something like that that would be
valuable right okay what do we need to
learn in order to do that well we need a
list of leads how do we represent a list
in programming well that's now we got to
learn about a Race So it's always that
way attacking it from the problem and
then down to the what code you need to
learn and never like you're going to
learn JavaScript here are the five main
data types Primitives and complex data
types like we very like opinionated in
that kind of way of teaching and I think
it it's not for everyone but we have
definitely found our kind of uh yeah
niche in the market of people who like
to learn that way yeah awesome well one
thing that uh I'm very excited to talk
with you about is the burgeoning field
of AI engineering now yeah AI
engineering of course my friend uh I
guess our mutual friend Sean Wang
recently had a big AI engineer Summit uh
in San Francisco were were you there no
froa our co-founder third co-founder he
was there okay cool yeah I didn't I
didn't get to make it but I did talk to
him on a previous episode of the free
cam podcast about AI engineering but you
are teaching it and yeah you've made it
a core focus of scrimba you know you're
a a smaller company you have limited
resources in terms of what topics you
can teach and you decided this is what
we're investing our scarce time energy
teaching talent in and you've created an
AI engineering uh curriculum yeah can
you talk a little bit about what a AI
engineering
is yeah so I think most people who hear
uh the phrase AI engineering uh thinks
it's more like an AI researcher or
machine learning researcher meaning a
person who uh trains models and um
writes algorithms for for for AI models
and it deploys the models and like stuff
like that that's not that at all uh it's
much much easier than that it's all and
it's much closer to a web developer role
it is all about taking the these um AI
apis that are out there these days or or
or you could host them your the open
source versions yourself but not like
not train them uh yourself and not write
the algorithms for them yourself it is
about being that kind of top um final
layer or final ux layer where you take
this amazing new technology and build
Next Generation apps with it using like
text voice images everything that is
popped up over the last few years in
generative Ai and it's like it's just so
exciting what you can do with it and and
and it's a feels like a green field out
there where you can just pick new
business areas and and industries which
haven't gotten AI properly applied um or
there AI hasn't been applied to it yet H
so so we we just see so many
opportunities out there and and had I
been a beginner and I today I would have
jumped on it immediately uh cuz I think
it's great for people's web developers
careers these days so so that's why
we're we're we're kind of going all in
and we want to be the best place to
learn that uh because while it isn't
that hard to learn uh actually it is
very overwhelming and easy to go into uh
kind of RAB go down rabbit holes uh and
get confused and get paralyzes by
analysis and stuff like that yeah so we
trying to yeah that that's why we're
we're going all in yeah so maybe you
could talk a little bit of about uh you
said it's not that hard to learn uh but
what to learn specifically and not yeah
you know getting Hacker News syndrome
where you're just looking at like the
latest release of whatever oh I need to
learn this you know focusing on the core
skills the foundation upon which you can
build out the rest of your skill set uh
maybe you could talk about what those
core skills of an AI engineer is and
just to be completely clear AI engineer
is somebody not necessarily a machine
learning engineer as you said who's
actually training models but other
skills to be able to essentially create
like good output from AI or or relevant
out output I mean that's how I would
very naively describe it does does that
make sense uh please feel free to extend
that definition no no it makes sense I
but I would say not just create relevant
output but create uh experiences from it
because it I think I think it it one
thing that was an epiphany for me was
that chat GPT 3.5 uh when like when chat
GPT came and it was like GPT 3.5 and not
3.0 yes it was better than 3.0 but I
think the actual true um um Innovation
there or or just as big of an innovation
was the the ux the fact that you just
chatted with it I mean if had you tried
gpt3 in the playground or or a gpt3
based product two months before chat GPT
was launched it or I at least got
equally mind blown uh when I when I saw
that so the techn take off the yeah the
user
experience uh so that is being able to
have a discussion and be able to drill
deeper into it because I also like used
like the various playgrounds from the
previous versions of GPT and I was like
this is cool but this is not ready I
don't see how I could really use this
Beyond you know creating spam or
something like that but but once I
really sat down especially with GPT 4 in
in the but but you're right chat GPT was
the key Innovation and open AI didn't
see it as the key Innovation they were
just like oh this is just some tech demo
essentially is is my understanding is
kind of how they shipped it but once
they saw the usefulness in terms of
being able to have conversations is
great I you know I use GPT I don't know
10 15 times a day to to ask about
various things I use it all the time in
language learning for example like full
discussions with it in foreign languages
and that's incredibly helpful it's like
having like a language tutor for free
right uh so but not to get too too deep
into that but I I think what what you
just said there that the chat interface
and the ability to iterate on your
initial prompt and to delve deeper and
to branch and all that stuff that that
was a huge Revelation for me personally
it sounds like it was for you as
well yeah it was H and
um I think there's so many more
discoveries in that application or ux
layer uh to to be found over the next
few years and and very often you also
need uh in order to to make to get a
great experience you also need the
context of the product you're working in
so yeah it works well to to use chat GPT
uh alongside when you're for example
coding but when you try
copilot or or or any of these other
uh tools coding tools that really put it
in put the AI in context for you then
you realize oh wow this is much better H
and I think that goes for all Industries
and professions uh that will be uh over
the next few years
um heavily changed uh as a consequence
of this so and what does that mean well
it means that there's a ton of work for
developers to do in order to build these
features and discover these features and
especially now that multimodality with
voice is is becoming more and more uh
streamlined as well yeah just it's like
being back in in like right after app
store was launched I think and there
just like so many opportunities out
there yeah now one thing I'll push back
on about the App Store is a lot of the
best immediate applications that came
out of the App Store were just folded
back into iOS itself for example there
was a time when you could publish a
flashlight app and get millions of
downloads and everybody be like oh this
is amazing because all you're really
doing is using like the the API to like
turn on the LED on the back of the thing
right and you create a cool you could
have the coolest flashlight interface in
the world but if you open up your phone
and uh now you just swipe down and you
can just hit the flashlight button and
that's so much easier than trying to
find a specific flashlight app and going
to the trouble of installing it and all
that like and GPT is already kind of
like like like or I guess the GPT
Company open AI has already kind of like
demonstrated uh a willingness to quickly
like grab some of the most killer apps
and like fold them into chat GPT itself
for example like do you think that um
there's going to be like these obvious
kind of applications that are going to
get folded in but then if you look at
the App Store obviously plenty of apps
have prospered uh it's it's like a
multi- billion dollar a year ecosystem
at this point you you think similar like
that GPT specifically and and some of
the other llms will have these big app
ecosystems or are you thinking more like
more like building Enterprise apps on
top of these or
both yeah so I
mean probably both things will happen
like open AI will take a lot of the use
cases and just fold it into chat GPT and
that'll kill a lot of startups
that most likely they were already
trying to do it it simultaneously I
think as well like as I said with with
the context being the product as well
for example what I've used and I'm
really impressed by is Loom if you've
tried that um video service you easily
create videos and uh they've just
integrated AI in such a useful and good
way where it
automatically creates chapters and
summaries and edits and like so many
things it does and it it like chat GPT
or or open AI couldn't have done that
without building a full like Loom
competitor and they can't build
competitors for all companies in the
world uh I think and and I think it's
that that'll just be a losing game I
think yeah awesome well I'm very excited
to see what happens with the ecosystem
I'm also excited to see what happens
with open source models have you been
following development of these open
source foundational models
yeah so I think it like was quite
surprised at how quickly they kind of
catched up to to chant
GPT at least I mean it still is the gold
standard with GPT 4 but um I wouldn't
have thought straight straight out of
like U 202 at the end of 2022 that uh
llama for example that Facebook would
come with with with such a good model
just a few months after it feels like
feels like they all knew this was coming
and they were ready there someone just
need to needed to take the first step
and then all the others came with their
own Foundation
models but yeah so I've been following
that and I think there's many
interesting things uh with that and has
for example the cost which turns out to
be uh quite challenging when using open
AI huge element uh of it uh having the
control uh internally of the model
yourself uh having being able to put
your own guard rails around it to to a
larger degree yeah and also running it
on device I think is super interesting
which I've been been checking out or
experimenting with in the browser for
for one I'll add one thing I'll just
jump into ad being able to add your own
proprietary data to it without worrying
about it leaking uh and being
extractable from you know gpc4 like like
you can kind of like get it you can do
tricks to get it to reveal it training
data and stuff like that and if you
could do that and your data that you've
put it into GPT 4 GPT 5 or whatever is
part of the training data or or that
some of the information you've already
used somehow made it into the next
version proprietary you know Trade
Secrets could essentially be extracted
that way so it's a security
consideration um sorry I didn't mean to
derail but but no no but it's a great
Point like so running on device your own
data your own guard rails um so many
reasons why having your own model that's
potentially running on on your own
servers is Superior in a lot of use
cases and of course cost uh because
gp4 it's expensive to run a model that
massive uh it occurred to me that a lot
of people may not even know what some of
these terms that we're using like
Foundation model mean so figured maybe
we could do a quick uh question and
answer session where you could quickly
Define some of these terms that people
are likely hearing when they hear about
AI engineering let's start with
Foundation
model yeah so so that's the kind of uh
models that can do not one thing not one
narrow use case but they are kind of
foundational they have some kind of
generalized intelligence I would say h
and they can
do language uh they can talk as a human
they can do generate code uh they can
they are multimodal much of the or many
times multim modals they can deal with
images uh and stuff like that so kind of
more general not the old kind of narrow
classification AI that can just spot a
cat in an image and just do that no a
foundation model can do many different
things okay and what is
embedding yeah so an embedding is I
think it's a ma mathematical expression
which um means to take one object and
put it into a new space just a bit
abstract but um essentially what it
means is that you take from for example
one object a paragraph about uh dogs for
example and you turn that into you
transform that into just a long array of
uh numbers of floating Point numbers and
those
numbers then are a representation of the
underlying meaning of that sentence they
are an embedding of that paragraph uh
but they are of course in a different
space since they're now numbers and not
like
text yeah so that they can
essentially play a part in I guess the
weightings and how the neural network
decides what output to get um
and oh go ahead no because then you can
actually it's quite cool to see see
visualizations of this which we have in
our our embeddings course uh where you
kind of see that it's very easy Once you
have something in an array of numbers
it's very easy to mathematically compare
the two and the distance between the two
so that's how the AI can know that once
it has two array two embeddings one of
dog and one of cat and one of Saturn
it'll it'll see that mathematically dog
and cat are closer to each other than
Saturn and know that oh these two things
make are somewhat semantically connected
and what is r a rag as some as people
sometimes refer to it
quickly so it's one of these uh threel
acronyms that scare beginners off but
aren't really that complex I feel like
developers sometimes like try to come up
with with with three-letter acronyms
that are uh just to make it hard for
people to kind of to understand what
they're doing it's not just developers
the government loves to come up with
three-letter acronyms in the military
and yeah maybe maybe it's a human thing
to the kind of uh Define The In Crowd
and the out crowd anyway okay I'll get
to the point so um rag retrieval
augmented generation imagine that you
have a company uh and you have a bunch
of internal data that and you want to
create a knowledge Bank where where
employees can ask for example like uh
what's the vacation policy or refund
policy for receipts and blah blah blah
that that's obviously data that don't
live in chat gpt's uh model or live in
their model it's data that lives in a
vect or that lives um when you use rag
in a vector database in the form of a
embeddings so uh rag means that you when
you ask the question about what's our
vacation policy like the app heads over
to a vector database and figures out
through your your question and the
embeddings that are there and the ma
mathematical calculations for for for
calculating distance between embeddings
it it manages to find the the the
information it needs to reply to your
question with the the kind of close data
that you have in your
company uh and and then you then you use
chat GPT to or or whatever AI API
whatever Foundation model you use to to
turn that into more of a conversational
reply with the the the data that you
fetched via the like the rag um approach
if that made sense so rag is essentially
a way that you can uh take your own data
and get it uh where it can easily
quickly interface as opposed to I mean
GPT 4 for example can now go and
searching with Bing and can pull stuff
up too like if I ask like what's the
vacation policy of fre C Camp uh or
something like that uh then it could
potentially scav the web and find that
particular thing but it's so much faster
if you've got retrieval augmented
generation right um rag so it's just one
of those things that speeds things up
and and ultimately reduces cost because
one thing that people may not realize
when they're using chat GPT is
every single query costs like I don't
know like 20 cents or something it's it
adds up very quickly like just sitting
there talking about like He-Man or
something or like the Doom Eternal like
lore or something like that which I was
I was talking with it about yesterday
like that I I cost open AI probably like
four or five bucks for my discussion
there right and that's why they're
taking so much money because it's very
expensive but R offers a way to
potentially dramatically reduce costs um
when you're yeah and also
less hallucination as you kind of as
it's able to get the the right data uh
in the prompt like so the result from
from from querying the vector databases
so then used in The Prompt so to make
the prompt more uh specific and um yeah
yeah so I mean you mentioned the term
hallucination which is a fun way it we
come up for like essentially returning
misinformation uh yeah but uh
models hallucinated all the time early
on uh and yeah like GPT 4 has gotten way
better about that by the way like and it
may not just be that gp4 has gotten
better but also subconsciously like I
might just say oh I think that's wrong
like I doubt it more so like as people
use these models they're going to become
more uh skeptical and they're going to
give her intuition for like okay does it
really know what it's talking about or
is it just is it just uh you know
spitballing here you know uh and yeah so
there are so many things you can do do
to reduce those hallucinations and if
you're talking about like a customer
facing app you don't want it to like
hallucinate your price of some product
or something like that that could
potentially be very catastrophic uh or
you don't you don't want us to like
hallucinate like legally binding
contracts or something like that right
um so yeah that is something that well
let's talk a little bit about like AI
engineering and like what it is that AI
Engineers seek to do because we already
have you know chat GPT and and we have
the open AI
API obviously using AI apis like that
are part of the AI engineer role but
maybe you can talk about like what the
main work to be done what the open roles
are talk about the field of AI
engineering and maybe give people who
are watching this listening to
this a pitch for why they should
consider becoming AI Engineers if
they're already working as a front-end
developer a full stack
developer yeah so why should they I
think uh economically it's a good idea
because there are just so many managers
and uh business owners out there today
who feel that uh the AI train is leaving
the station and their company is not on
it but maybe their competitors are so
being a little bit cynical using that uh
kind of uh anxiety uh that is in a lot
of companies these days with good reason
I would say
h it will definitely help your career if
you're the kind of person that can step
up and say hey actually I know some
really cool features and and Next
Generation things we can build into our
or at least experiment with uh in our
product by using these API because I
know all about rag I know how to create
an AI agent I know the AI safety prompt
injection uh risks we need to think
about uh and I know how to do open
source models for example I mean if you
if you can come with a pitch like that
to your to your boss or to to to a
company you want to work for I think
it's it's definitely going to open doors
uh yeah and it's it's what I would do
when I if I had been a beginner now and
actually it's also what I would do
hadn't I been uh running scrimba I would
just probably spend all my time just
experimenting with building new kinds of
experiences so so that's a fun part I I
think um it's it's a lot of fun and and
uh it's good for good for your career
that's um I think why why people should
jump on it so how would you recommend
somebody who's interested in breaking
into Tech maybe they're learning the
code how would you recommend they start
using Ai and how do they what should
they do to get on the fast track to
understanding these tools and being able
to leverage
them yeah obviously I got to plug our
scrimba AI engineering path that that'll
kind of take you take you on the fast
lane but uh all that aside assuming that
you've actually uh learned it one way or
another I think there's so many cool
things you can do to get attention these
days and and get get kind of a an edge
on the rest of the um on the rest of the
market or the rest of the job Seekers
out there what I would have done today I
would have actually found my ideal
company that I wanted to work for and
then I would have uh thought as an AI
engineer a what does what what does the
dream product or what's one one AI
product that this company should have or
that it will have in three years maybe
it's you want to really want to work for
for the biggest law firm in your uh your
town right then then I would like okay
what's what's an like Law plus AI
there's just so many ideas so many
things you can do to help lawyers draft
documents or read through uh previous
law uh law documents ments about um
right yeah about um what's the word
president uh pres president yeah for
example like that or legal president so
many things that can be done uh or or
marketing tools like quickly help you
with your your uh problem uh with your
tax problem or just b a bot for that
whatever there's so many ways you can go
to companies these days and say hey look
at this prototype I've built
you should really have such a tool in
house how about you just hire me and
I'll start building these kinds of
things for you that that's how I would
would try to get my foot in the door in
the tech industry today had I been a
complete beginner wow okay so just a
just a recapitulate what you just said
instead of applying you know through web
forms or or going to networking events
you can do that too but like to build a
prototype specifically for the company
and say hey have you considered adding
this this to this product and using that
as a way to potentially get hired on to
build precisely that so almost kind of
like inventing your own job within that
company and your own product or
extension of an existing
product exactly you could even I mean if
you really want to go go the last mile
you deploy it with their design on a URL
that resembles theirs and like just send
it over to them as if fully branded
product as well and yeah
just don't try that with so many doors
cuz in software they created like a a
version of Mario that ran on uh windows
or or Doss I guess and and Nintendo was
like don't distribute this or we'll sue
you so it won't it may backfire in some
situations but like if you're
approaching like probably a big American
tech company maybe they'll be more
acceptive
sorry that person's career though that
did it I mean they went on to create
great things and it bolstered their
reputation uh for being the first you
know company to essentially get
sidescrolling games working on Doss so
yeah yeah I mean it worked out fine for
them obviously they're all who who was
it did you say in software the the
creators of Doom and oh oh oh yeah all
those games yeah but but originally they
were I read that book masters of Doom
but uh forgot about that chapter amazing
book so uh it's been an amazing time
talking with you I've learned so much
about a AI engineering and where you
think things are heading we've also
heard a whole lot of practical tips for
how you can incorporate AI into your
daily workflow and potentially learn
these tools and go out and create a role
for yourself at your dream company so uh
per I just want to thank you again for
coming on the free code Camp podcast
it's been a pleasure man likewise and uh
thank you so much for for having me and
for being a scrimba supporter ever since
uh day one yeah yeah again just I love
the invention the discovery that is uh
scriba so it's it's been amazing to
follow your journey over the years and
uh excited to talk with you again in the
future um everybody watching this until
next week happy
coding happy coding